في هذه الاثناء قال مراسل الجزيره ان
القياده عمليات الجنوب الاوكرانيه اعلنت
حاله التاهب الجوي جنوبي البلاد واعلنت ان
الروسي عززوا مواقعهم ليله السبت في البحر
الاسود باربع حاملات الصواريخ من نوع كلمه
الدفاعات الجويه اسقطت مسيرات روسيه وان
خطر الهجمات متواصل كان مراسلنا فدى بوقوع
انفجارات عده الليل الماضيه وسط ميكو لايف
جنوبيه اوكرانيا التي السلطات انها رصدت
اطلاق صواريخ روسيا من البحر الاسود
باتجاه المقاطعه واضاف مراسلنا ان
انفجارات عده وقعت
فيرسون اللتين اعلنت السلطات فيهما مقتل
سته من موظفي ازاله الالغام في قصف روسي
بينما قالت القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه ان
دفاعاتها الجويه اسقطت خمسه مسيرات
انتحاريه روسيه خلال يوم امس السبت
لوكاله الطاقه الذريه رافاييل غروسيا
البدء باجلاء السكان من مدينه انرجودار
الاوكرانيه حيث توجد محطه
من تزايد الاعمال العسكريه في منطقه
المحطه التي تسيطر عليها القوات الروسيه
قالت السلطات الاوكرانيه في مدينه نيكو
بول ان مدنيا قتل واصيب اخرون في قصف روسي
استهدف مناطق ماهوله بالسكان واضافت
السلطات مدينه التابعه لمقاطعه دينيبر
البلاد والمطله على محطه نوويه ان القصف
بالمدفعيه الثقيله دمر سبعه منازل اضافه
الى احد المباني مؤكده تضرر ثلاثه خطوط
انابيب للغاز وخط للكهرباء